toutes nos données numériques photos
mails transitent par des câbles sur
terre sous la mer mais aussi dans de
gigantesques datacenter ces hangars hors
norme rempli de serveurs et disques durs
il y en aurait environ 4800 répartis sur
la planète
le souci c'est que ces installations
informatiques fonctionnent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 et pour éviter la
surchauffe des normes climatiseurs sont
déployés une aberration à l'heure où la
question écologique est au centre des
préoccupations
quel impact sur la planète ces data
center aurons dans les années à venir
comment les rendre plus écologique
aujourd'hui on construit des attaques
center toutes les semaines certains data
center représente une consommation
comparable à la production quasiment
d'une d'une centrale nucléaire toutes
les éoliennes françaises ne suffirait
pas à alimenter les datacenter de france
et on projette de x 4 à peu près cette
consommation d'ici 10 ans 40% de la
facture d'électricité d'un datacenter
servirait à alimenter les serveurs et
les 60% restants à les refroidir avec
des climatiseurs géant
du côté d'annecy à l'abri des regards
une entreprise développe un nouveau
système ingénieux qui rend la
climatisation obsolète un serveur sachot
et aujourd'hui quand on fait un
datacenter qu'est-ce qu'on fait part on
fait un datacenter qui va faire entre 5
et 7 mètres de haut d'accord on va voir
des faux plancher on va avoir des faux
plafonds on va voir un système de clip
on va avoir un système de circulation
d'air des ailefroide d une chose tout ça
pour quoi pour refroidir dans un serveur
1 point selon serge le fondateur de
l'entreprise a décidé de changer de
paradigme en partant d'un constat simple
si j'avais une coupe de champagne dans
maman prenons un petit peu d'imagination
et que c'est le coupe de champagne je
veux la refroidir qu'est ce que je fais
je refroidi le champagne ou se refroidit
toute la pièce dans lequel ya le
champagne on refera ni le champagne
l'image peut surprendre les composants
électroniques les serveurs et leur
connectique complexes sont plongés dans
un bain d'huile comme dans une sorte de
friteuse sans que le matériel
informatique ne soit altérée l'huile est
un liquide non conducteurs qui absorbent
jusqu'à 1500 fois plus de chaleur que
l'eire grâce à un circuit de
refroidissement
l'huile est maintenu à 17 degrés un
système qui dans trois ans pourrait
avoir un impact direct sur notre planète
si tout le monde datacenter city on
passerait de 20 % de l'électricité
mondiale à 4 % ce qui veut dire que on
économiserait la bagatelle de 1500
centrales nucléaires à un gigawatt si
pour certains l'enjeu est de refroidir
les serveurs en consommant moins
d'énergie d'autres ont préféré faire de
cette faiblesse une force nous avons
rendez vous chez carnot
initialement ça a été de proposer une
alternative vertueuse au datacenter ces
grandes usines du numérique qui aligne
des milliers d'ordinateurs qui tournent
jour et nuit le concept de carnot a été
justement de vouloir faire quelque chose
de cette chaleur de la valoriser pour
chauffer les bâtiments pour chauffer des
piscines pour chauffer des entrepôts
pour chauffer des sites industriels
arrêtez de refroidir à tout prix les
bâtiments abritant des datacenters et
réutiliser cette chaleur autrement dit
faire du déchet les uns la ressource d
autres
saluent louis
ça roule et c'est dans le garage de
l'entreprise que l'idée a vu le jour une
chaudière en apparence comme les autres
à quelques détails près
ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur des
chaudières c'est ce que j'ai dans les
mains des processeurs informatiques des
barrettes de ram des cartes
électroniques et c'est de cette chaleur
la chaleur des processeurs dont on va se
servir pour chauffer de l'eau à plus de
60° un modèle de chaudières comme celui
ci si on en a deux ou trois on arrive à
produire jusqu'à 50 % de l'eau chaude
nécessaire à une cinquantaine de
logements un système vertueux et
sécurisant pour les clients plutôt que
de concentrer les ordinateurs en un seul
lieu un datacenter carnot les distribuer
les décentralise directement là où la
chaleur va être bénéfique donc notre
approche à nous elle est distribuée les
serveurs ou plutôt les chaudières sont
répartis dans des dizaines de bâtiments
partout dans le monde en cas de panne ou
d' incendies une infime partie des
données seraient touchés aujourd'hui les
idées fleurissent pour lutter contre la
pollution numérique mais l' influence de
la france restent limités la grande
majorité des data center se trouve au
delà de nos frontières
[Musique]